[Applause]
happy
thursday everyone and boy is it a happy
one because i've almost made it through
the week without being stabbed or shot
although twice security stopped dana
perino just in time
but all of us here in this studio have
something in common we aren't dead
at least yet because in new york city
not getting assaulted is akin to winning
the lottery it's a violent city right
now this morning i saw a rat with a
black eye
it's a funny image
not even a real joke but hey murders
spiked big time jumping from 319 in 2019
to 500 in 2020. now we shy away uh from
numbers around here because cat hates
math
but change that vowel to an e and that's
another
another story
right okay
[Laughter]
that jump by the way was the largest
since national record keeping began in
1960. that was the year the mob finally
stopped killing all the record keepers
so yes we may not be number one anymore
in math or science but check out how we
kill each other
where's our gold medal in that we got to
host the olympic games so we can add
competitive drive-bys as a new sport
but as the media quickly points out all
the time if you remove murder from the
statistics crime has dropped
well that's a relief
so
so hey honey did you hear this year
you're less likely to get robbed
why aren't you answering me
oh wow you've been murdered
but at least you weren't robbed
now let me move your body before i get
arrested for littering now maybe i'm
crazy but if murder nearly doubles while
lesser stuff is down
i'm not throwing a parade mainly because
no one will show up since they've all
been murdered
so the crime wave ain't just nyc either
chicago had 771 murders last year
compared to 500 the previous year la
went from 258 to 351. that's why these
cities are hemorrhaging residents
because the residents are hemorrhaging
murders have jumped 10 from 2020 in 87
cities according to the new york times
and speaking of murder you know it
killed the times to admit that
still the times is in full denial to
them it has nothing to do with defunding
and marginalizing law enforcement while
cheering on the destruction of cities or
releasing repeat violent offenders under
the streets which they have essentially
decriminalizing crime no no no it's not
that to quote a community organizer in
the piece quote people are desperate and
they don't have a lot of options so they
turn to violence as a way to solve
things
so is that a desperate person's only
option you know look for a job
or kill someone
congratulations media you've dressed the
city in a short skirt and said she was
asking for it
if you don't see the criminal as the
perpetrator but as a victim you happily
excuse yourself from punishing the perp
however the media would surely change
their minds if these crimes were being
committed by trump supporters
so what is new york city doing while
citizens are picked off like clay
pigeons at a skeet chute
well the board of health has declared
racism a public health crisis not murder
not mental illness not drug abuse not
pumpkin spiced lattes
but
racism those victims pushed onto the
subway tracks i bet they'll be so
relieved
so they passed a resolution declaring
that covid has worsened the suffering
among communities of color now if
they're referring to rest homes they
might be right black white brown racism
didn't kill them though the carelessness
and stupidity of our politicians did
one state senator brad hoyleman said we
need an urgent call to action we can no
longer ignore
as a government or society
yeah because we've been ignoring racism
sorry where's this idiot ben
the only place where racism isn't being
discussed ad nauseum is under the sea
and even there the great white shark
gets a bad rap
it's true
this resolution came six months after
the inept cdc declared racism a serious
public health threat
and now they've created a mayoral racial
justice commission who's going to be in
charge of it the mayor's wife
no
our mayor is stupid
who needs a punchline
but
his wife's worse
she
she ran the mental health program that
made 800 million bucks taxpayer money
disappear
as a result what's happening on our
streets looks like the trailer for the
sequel to one flew over the cuckoo's
nest it's crazy
so is racism a public health crisis
let's ask the angry black male
[Music]
oh hey cut phil
white devil
sorry
just
i'm not going to be in this week really
under the weather
under your oppression you
white devil
i'm sorry i got the i got the racism
really bad this week
oh fake
oh man i was really
hunky
oh
sorry you guys should probably go oh
but you know
i mean i guess you the good news devil
i'm sorry is
that you know it's not me personally
it's it's an illness
wonder break
wonder bread oh
so maybe it's true racism is a public
health crisis
if you're a racist
seriously if you think being a racist
offers you any advantage in life then
you're worse than a racist your joy read
the quickest way to end your life just
be a racist i would have added being
caught whacking off on a work zoom call
but cnn proved me wrong
but the left maintains you could be
guilty of racism without any proof at
all it's like dunking witches if they
float they're guilty but if they're
innocent they drown
and if they get hepatitis
the water is definitely from cat's hot
tub
you can call it systemic or unconscious
racism no matter what you call it it's
designed to get around your denial of
being a bigot your blood runs red white
and racist except for the accusers who
were somehow born without that evil gene
so is racism a problem sure but it
didn't rape that woman on the train in
philly while people filmed it it didn't
kill that filipino nurse in times square
two weeks ago racism didn't send that
other asian woman down a flight of
subway stairs to her death racism didn't
push people in front of trains racism
didn't force closures of stores that can
no longer keep up with retail theft
or wait maybe racism is behind this
because what else could be fueling the
denial of rising homicide rates that's
killing so many blacks the denial
exposes the underlying message from the
white elite activist class what do you
expect from these people that's the
racism and it's a true public health
crisis seriously if covent revealed
anything it's that living under democrat
leadership is the most dangerous
co-morbidity one could have
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests
he's a hockey fan who's not afraid to
ask what the [ __ ] vice president of
public relations for z labs chris barron
the brilliant economist always brings a
high interest rate financial analyst
heather zuma
he's birthed more tv successes than kris
jenner
tv writer and producer rob law
and she's the only person that olive
garden said wasn't family
fox news contributor captain
i got a lot of fans there cat
they're obviously drunk
rob when you see stuff like this do you
wonder how can this country survive when
we when lawlessness is now somehow
government approved and the citizens get
targeted by our very own agencies yeah
except that you know well the good news
is yes that the new york mayor is on his
way out and the guy on his way in
is you know went around the the boroughs
of manhattan and bureaus of new york
city and said what do you guys want in
places like brooklyn and queens and the
bronx and they said we want more cops
mm-hmm and he said okay yeah he ran on
that and he won and he's gonna win
probably you know it's a democratic city
he's a different he's a democratic
candidate right probably gonna win and
so you it is correcting itself a little
bit i mean what i'm most worried about i
think is more freaky to me is
that a lot of these crimes a lot of
these murders in new york city anyway
are are committed by insane people right
on the street
and that is a public health crisis yeah
oh no absolutely if you drive up any
avenue to like i do every day to work
because i'm a man of the people you
don't drive
my driver is it is it my driver drives
me can you see it through the through
the the tip the window is tinto
and i always tell the driver not to
speak to me or look at me so i can
capture right
but i mean you go up the street there
are people lying face down on the ground
and you can't do anything they're insane
heather to you you now you are a
business expert how is this affecting
like
businesses in any time this is a
nationwide issue there are businesses
that aren't coming back from covet and
then when they come back they deal with
crime right so the businesses that did
succeed especially small businesses
through the pandemic now they're having
to deal with the issue of when they call
the police if someone's robbing the
store nobody shows up on time right so
they have to shut down because they're
losing a lot of revenue due to all this
due to all the theft yeah and i i just
think when when the murder increase was
the highest year of the year since the
60s 77 percent of those were caused by
firearms so you will hear the democrats
blame guns right say guns are the
problem but it's not it's defunding the
police there's no surprise that surging
violence um in cities of minneapolis and
portland and new york and l.a are all
areas where they reduce the police
budgets i mean that's that that's no
coincidence so law enforcement risks
their lives every day to to save us and
i think they deserve a lot more respect
yeah
right
chris is it time to start defunding
things that democrats like uh yeah
absolutely like the arts yeah well no
so here's actually what the saddest
thing is is that uh the the left-wing
activists who say that like there's all
this desperation in the inner cities
they're absolutely correct unfortunately
the left doesn't have any policy
solutions right so what they offer up is
this empty rhetoric it's you know it's
racism it's bigotry it's homophobia they
have no actual agenda to get people off
the streets to get people working to
give people opportunity and that's what
this is all about it it is the the
complete the emperor has no clothes here
all they have is empty rhetoric and
that's why that's why we just continue
to see it over and over again literally
when you're on the streets of new york
sometimes the emperors
you know what though uh to your point
it's it's the problems that the left
concentrate on you can concentrate on in
times of luxury right the republicans
come to power they build an economy then
the democrats can come in and talk about
gender diversity but now we're in chaos
and they're still talking about like
things about like pronouns while
everybody's suffering it we need to get
the adults back in the room cat what do
you say
depends on which adults yeah and which
room
like i want more cops on the street for
sure do i want them you know searching
my apartment not necessarily oh god no
but it's in everybody sees it right like
i mean even uh
just yesterday there was a guy passed
out right across the sidewalk by my
apartment they will kind of like kill me
yeah and we were concerned we were like
is we were walking the dog like is he
dead we don't know we kind of walk and
he was like oh no i'm just taking a nap
it's like
i have taken naps before yes
you don't do it like that
yeah it is a uh the broken windows uh
theory has been right has been debunked
but we're finding that it was wrongly
debunked that if you allow certain
things like that happen it only gets oh
i allowed it we i invited him over
excellent
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else